in the heat of a narrowing contest the
front runner to be the next prime
minister we're going to do it and then
we're going to go smash labour at the
general election all right maybe the
favorite among mps but soon the pitch
will turn to tory members the dividing
line for rishi sunak
did you see yourself as a socialist
chancellor no absolutely not you know i
think the number one economic priority
we face as a country is inflation and i
want to get a grip of inflation because
inflation is what makes everybody poorer
and if we don't get a grip of it now it
will last longer and that's not a good
thing once we've done that i will
deliver tax cuts today the former
chancellor secured key red wool backing
from ben houchen the teas valley man
but in the studio spotlight it was the
underdog who polled best with the public
tom chickenhead is boris johnson an
honest man
and he's secured a key northern vote the
first part of this leadership election
was dominated by tax cuts and a sort of
almost a race to the bottom on tax tom
has said quite correctly that we're
going to cut fuel duty look i filled up
our family car yesterday it was over 100
pounds to fill the tank that is
completely unsustainable for families
meanwhile at chequers the outgoing prime
minister boris johnson is understood to
be holding a leaving do this weekend
leaving those vying to succeed him to
fight it out for the keys to number 10.
behind the scenes some tories say that
this has been a particularly unpleasant
leadership contest and last night on
questions about gender recognition and
the economy the gloves were definitely
off what people watching would have been
looking for is not just policy
differences but performance under
pressure particularly for those
candidates less used to the spotlight
people a very big stature went out very
very soon in the race and it seems as if
it's it's well it's febrile isn't it
it's um it's quite unpredictable so
these debates really matter this weekend
the people who did really well actually
were the the outsiders who everyone
expects to be knocked out even so it's
unlikely that tom tougan tat or kemi
baden will make it to the membership i
think that went very well i've never
done a televised debate before and i
more than held my own
as the final five are whittled down to
two there are still clear front runners
penny malden's team say she didn't
misstep but some were underwhelmed by
her performance last night liz trust was
criticized for being too stiff and the
former chancellor will continue to face
fire from all sides on the economy there
is no obvious route for the next prime
minister a weekend of media scrutiny
could tip the balance at the top ali
fortescue sky news